well
[Music]
hello how are you andrés gonzález
with the most outstanding headlines
for friday october 16 the
henderson police say that a kidnapping and a
chase ended in a shooting that
involved one of their officers it all
started with a call to the  911 call
from a man saying he had escaped
from another on lake mead parkway and back
highway when authorities arrived
on scene this man was no
longer there after a short
chase the man allegedly drew
a gun and pointed it at the officers they
they responded and managed to injure him
his health condition is unknown
early voting begins tomorrow in
nevada there will be 48 sites around
clark county on official
election day about 125 polling sites will open
so also vote by mail
for more information visit the
news now page  Spanish diagonal dotcom
several members
of the Journal's football program
tested positive for the  coronavirus with
the bid said that less than 12 and a half
percent of the team is affected,
including players, coaches and
assistants, those who are infected
are now complying with a
quarantine period the first game
will be in two weeks from
tomorrow
and now  We went through the weather forecast
there will be clear skies with
some breezes from the north the
maximum for today will be around 90
degrees for the weekend we will have
hot weather due to the low 90
degrees have a nice day I
greet you andrés gonzález and that was  your
iu news now news brief in
Spanish
[Music]